Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
People get crazy.
You know people get crazy.
Look,
look,
Brian is,
people go crazy too.
Everybody gets crazy.
People get crazy.
Like why did Rhonda charge after?
Why did she try to stand with,
with holly like that and charge after
it.
That's not the right attempt.
Right?
Like you,
she did a page.
What page was also at that VIP party and
Paige and I have spoken with were
friendly,
don't know her that well,
but anyway,
she felt the need.
She came out to Schick.
Nisha,
Nisha.
She's like,
I have to tell you this experience I had
with Rhonda.
And I'm like,
what?
And she's like,
well,
we were at a reebok deal just recently.
And she,
she's like,
we were at a shoot and she's like,
I was trying to find her so we could get
a picture.
And the Reebok people were like,
don't ask Rhonda for a picture.
And she's like,
why?
She's like,
just don't do,
just stay away from Rhonda.
Don't ask her for a picture.
She's like,
okay.
And I guess Ronda came later that day
and like seek trout and w there's like
cussed her out.
Like they've never really had a
conversation either.
She's like,
I don't know Rhonda,
like,
you know,
other than hi bye.
That's it.
And like,
I guess she came up,
Rodney came up,
I was like,
fuck you,
you fair weather bitch.
How dare you cross me,
Blah Blah,
blah.
She's like,
cross you,
what are you talking about?
And she was like,
you congratulated Holly Holm for beating
me,
so fuck you.
You fucking fairweather 115 pounds.
Like it was just like,
went off on page and page gave me,
told me,
and I was like,
honey,
welcome to my world.
She's like,
oh my gosh.
He's like,
I'm glad that I saw this side of her,
so I know,
you know,
I'm like,
well,
and she's like,
you know,
cause I didn't understand.
She's like,
I told her honor,
like,
I'm sorry if that offended you,
but you don't allowed to congratulate
whoever I want.
And um,
she's like,
because I congratulated Rosen,
I'm a eunice.
When she beat me.
I was like,
you know,
congratulations you what my ass.
That was a badass performance and she's
like,
you know,
I just simply told holly,
congratulations once again like it
wasn't anything,
you know anti Rhonda,
but Rhonda is just ripped her a new one.
Wow.
Do you have to be on team Rhonda for
life?
Yeah,
I guess I've never been on t Rhonda.
I'm good.
All or none because we have to assume
she's evolved.
Right,
but that's the best I think I've seen
her look so I have to assume like she's
going to be better than that even.
Do you have goals as far as like what
you want to do with the title?
Who,
how long do you want to hold it?
Do you have any thoughts in mind of like
must be opponents like is getting Rhonda
back in the Octagon?
Yeah,
that's important.
I need that.
Like that has to happen.
That's a very important to me and I have
Amanda had to me,
I do not want to look pastor because
they think that would be a huge mistake.
It's not one that I want to make as a
veteran in my career.
That would be a rookie move.
Um,
but you know,
in the back of my mind,
of course,
like the fight with Ronda is something I
want to happen and you don't know when
it will happen.
It could be anticipated for November.
I've heard that be tossed around in the
UFC that you,
she's planning on coming back and maybe
it might be Madison Square Garden.
That would be great.
I want to focus on that.
I want to focus on Amanda,
but I know in the back of my mind and I
want,
I want that fight.
Like I want that to happen.
I think it's so important to me in my
career to go and beat Ronda and prove
everyone else.
Like I've been an underdog in most of my
fights.
I've been the person that people have
always counted out in my entire career,
my entire life.
Most people are telling me,
you can't,
you couldn't,
you shouldn't,
you wouldn't.
And I'm,
you know,
that's,
I'm fine with that.
I'm perfectly fine with that.
I am at the best point in my career and
Rhonda is at the worst.
You know,
she's going through what I've already
been through time and time again and I
have built myself back up from that
point,
time and time again.
I know that I can do that.
I'm confident in that.
Here I am standing the strongest that
I've ever stood and I've already been
through that.
I've already been head kicked and
knocked out.
That happened to me before.
Like I picked myself up,
but pull myself up by my bootstraps,
but one for back in front of the other
and worked.
Got My strike first world title,
I lost that you're on to pick myself
back up.
But one funder for the other got back on
the horse.
Fought,
fought,
fought Ronda again.
The EOC was devastated,
crushed,
thought my world was just falling down
around me,
coming to an end cap.
Pekka put one foot in front,
the other gal back on the horse.
And now here I am,
the world champion.
You know,
I know that I'm tough.
I know that I have what it takes to beat
Ronda.
Many people don't believe that that's
okay.
I've been in this position before.
Many be,
most people didn't think I was going to
be holly.
He most people didn't think he was gonna
beat Ronda.
It doesn't matter to me what other
people think.
It matters what I believe and what I
know.
And um,
the question mark is what,
how is Rhonda going to come back from
this?
I know what I've been hearing from
Rhonda in the media and the press.
Um,
she's been a little quiet lately,
but before that it wasn't what I would
have expected to hear from someone who
really wants to come back and who's
really,
really a fighter at the core.
She's a great athlete.
She's a great fighter.
She's accomplished a lot of things,
credit where credit's due,
you know,
I give her a round of applause for
everything she's been able to
accomplish.
I'll tell you what,
every time I've ever lost in my career,
I went bananas to get back in their
ballistic.
I was like,
I have to like right now,
just like holly was like,
they're like,
when do you want to fight again?
She's like tomorrow against Meesha.
Now that's what you want to hear.
When someone has a devastating loss,
they want to get back in there right now
and face that person right now or,
or someone else,
just get that loss of the record.
Erase it.
When I lost the cat Zingano,
I freaked out.
I called Sean Shelby and I was like,
get me another fight right now.
He's like,
your nose isn't even heal.
I don't give a fuck.
I wanna I wanna fight.
I want it now.
I want to know when it's coming up like
right now or I'm going to freak out.
I don't know what to tell you,
but I'm going to lose my shit if I don't
have like a fight on the horizon,
lose it.
And then I hear Rhonda like,
Oh,
I'm going to take a year off and I'm
going to,
you know,
I'm going to do this.
I'm gonna.
I'm like,
that just doesn't sound like someone who
really wants this anymore.
And I think that fight might've broker
that could be wrong,
but I think something inside of her is
different than it was before.
Um,
maybe she's not broken,
but it's different because how much do
you think of factor
is,
how much of a factor do you think
success is in the park in terms of she's
doing movies.
She's,
she was,
uh,
the darling of all these late night
television shows and everybody wanted to
hang out with her.
Is doing these commercials with,
you know,
seth rogen on television.
Like how much of a factor is that?
Well,
she asked the curity,
now she has job security outside the
FCC.
She doesn't really need that anymore.
And I think maybe that's also something
on her mind is like,
does she really want this?
Because winning is awesome.
It's great.
It's easy.
It's like when you win,
everybody loves you.
Everybody supports you.
Everybody's there.
Everybody's on your train.
When you lose fucking sucks.
It sucks.
And only the people that really love
your still really,
really there for you.
Everyone else was just like,
yeah,
whatever.
That's loser.
And then you have the social media,
you know,
white nights that come out and want to
tell you what a piece of shit you are
and how you're never going to accomplish
anything and you'll never win another
fight.
And you might as well just quit and
retire,
blah,
blah.
See those people and you have to make a
choice,
you know?
And,
and my choice has always been the,
to do,
to,
to keep fighting,
you know,
and it,
and it just don't,
I don't recognize,
there's a lot of things I recognize in
Ronda that I can,
I can recognize her greatness.
I can recognize,
you know,
her championship.
I can recognize things I don't identify
with that I don't identify with sitting
on that loss for a year.
I cannot understand it.
If it was me,
it would have eaten me alive inside and
out.
Tend to,
I couldn't have done it.
I couldn't be making a movie.
I couldn't be doing that.
I would,
it would just,
but did she,
I don't think she has a choice.
I think if you have movie contracts,
I think you have to fulfill them.
Do you,
I dunno,
it is conor have to show up for showing
up or press conferences is one thing,
but I don't think,
I think she could've,
she could've fought because they said
they had anticipated for her to come
back at UFC 200.
They wanted that and they,
and,
and Dana said she could have,
but should she,
she could have,
well,
I think that could have and should,
she was because she had to do a movie
for three months.
So like doing the movie for three months
would have taken three months outside of
our camp.
And you've done a movie before,
you know what it's like you're on the
set all day,
16 hour days.
It's long and grueling.
You don't have time to train.
Yeah.
But after a loss like that,
I think you really have to have enough
time to actually focus in then on top of
that to getting,
getting flatlined like that.
Like you have to have,
uh,
some time to recover.
You recover your head.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I just don't know if a year that would,
I'm just saying that would crush me.
I wouldn't be able to do what she's
doing right now.
I wouldn't physically be able to like to
deal with that for your and,
and if I had to think of it,
eat me alive,
like I think I'd be so depressed.
And so I'm pretty sure it's eating her
alive too.
But how do you sit on it for a year
then?
How do you do that?
Do what you gotta do?
I can't,
I couldn't,
well,
you know,
it's all speculation.
We only,
we don't know until she comes back.
But the other thing too is like,
you know,
she's like,
she had her,
you know,
her downs,
her,
her really,
really low,
which I empathize with.
I've been there,
um,
you know,
but then she said,
I was thinking about,
you know,
these all these negative thoughts and,
and um,
then I looked up on the island and she
said this on my own show.
I looked up and I saw Travis Brown and I
realized,
you know,
I've got to stick around to have his
babies.
And I thought like what?
What went through my mind is like,
I gotta get back and get my title back.
I gotta to get back and like win a
fight.
Like it.
It just seemed like her mindset is
different than what I would expect a
fighter's mindset to be.
Does that make sense at all?
Like what?
I'm trying,
what I'm saying it's like it didn't seem
like her motivation was to to fight and
win again.
It was,
there was other things,
and I'm not saying she's not going to
come back and be great or come back and
fight.
I'm not questioning that.
I'm questioning where her true
motivation is coming from because I
think while she was winning,
it was so awesome.
Like she's like,
well yeah,
I'm want to keep doing this.
Of course I'm going to keep a keep them
crushing girls.
I'm demolishing them.
I'm the star.
All these great things are coming now.
She already has that.
She's already making movies.
She already has millions of millions of
dollars.
Is Her true motivation?
Was it just,
you know,
keeping that undefeated streak because
she talked about that so much.
You know,
I will retire undefeated w and then she,
she even said like,
I don't,
you know,
I'm questioning what am I doing now?
Like,
you know,
now I'm not going to ever retire
undefeated.
So what is my,
you know,
maybe I'm meant for this.
Maybe I meant she doesn't really know
that was her identity.
It was like to be undefeated in this
sport.
So if,
if that's not the goal anymore,
I just don't know.
Like I feel like I sent something off,
I sent something is not right in her
mindset and I think she's going to come
back and I think she's going to fight
anything.
She'll fight hard,
but I just don't know if she still has
it after a brutal loss like that,
you know,
if she's still hungry enough,
those are fighting words.
Yeah.
Is She hungry?
Not,
that's the question.
What you're doing right now is you're,
you're throwing up the bat signal,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
that's how I feel.
A lot of shit because people were like,
oh,
you know what,
don't,
I don't,
I don't apologize for anything that I
say unless I really say it's something
that was,
that I didn't mean to say that was
hurtful to someone and I'm like,
oh,
I fucked up.
But honestly,
if it's my opinion is my opinion,
if you don't like it,
I'm not,
I'm not gonna apologize for my opinion.
You're going to apologize for anything
that I,
you know,
that had to say about the way I feel
about Rhonda,
the way I feel about any,
any of these situations,
you know?
So I've just,
I'm,
I'm going to be as transparent as an
end.
I don't think you're saying anything
disrespectful either.
And I don't think,
I think as a champion,
and that's what you are,
you,
you're analyzing someone's mindset and
you're totally entitled to that.
Yeah.
And I have a lot of respect for Rhonda
as an athlete.
You know,
a lot like,
I just think you'll ever be friends
after it's all said and done.
Never.
I don't think so.
No.
I think she thinks that I've done so
many things and like I don't think she
would ever,
I think she blames me for things that I
didn't even do.
So,
I mean,
how do you even get around that?
Right.
You know,
like I heard what you guys did your
interview,
she said something like,
then I called a promotion and like tried
to get crispy.
Oh,
like,
um,
mess with him before,
like his fight or something that,
that,
that I guess he,
I guess he was contracted to another
promotion and he wasn't supposed to be
while he was on the ultimate fighter.
And I guess that that Dana received a
call and then they thought that I,
she thought that I did that.
I'm like,
first of,
first of all,
like I didn't even know he signed to
another organization at all.
And if you,
you know,
like if he was,
it didn't even,
wouldn't have even crossed my mind.
Like I'm too,
like you said,
I'm too easy going to even think of
something like that.
And I'm not malicious by any means.
I've nothing against Krispy [inaudible],
but I think she thought that I tried to
like mess with him.
Like I called the promoter of whatever
organization,
little small contract.
Don't even know how I would have known
that.
How would you even know that?
How do you know?
But this is the same girl that ripped
page for,
for congratulating holly.
Like she has her way of thinking and
she's going to hate me until the day she
dies and I'm okay with that.
That's fine.
We don't need to be friends.
That's okay.
You know?
I'm perfectly fine with that.
Yeah.
[inaudible].